>> Bret: FORMER CHIEF OF
STAFF, THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
NOW, THE OTHER SIDE WE WELCOME
AND FORMER BALTIMORE MAYOR,
STEPHANIE RAWLINGS BLAKE, BADHAM
ERIC, THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
YOU HEARD THAT FROM
THE ESTATE OF THE RACE, WHERE
YOU SEE IT AND I?
>> I THINK IT’S IMPORTANT TO BE
UP IN THE POLE AND WE KNOW THAT
THE MOST IMPORTANT POLE IS
ELECTION DAY AND THE TEAM THAT
WE FELT KNOWING THAT THE POLLS
AND WHAT THEY BRING
HILLARY CLINTON FOUR YEARS AGO
AND KNOWINGLY THE ULTIMATE
OUTCOME.
I THINK EVERYBODY UNDERSTANDS
THE PRICE THAT IT PAID WHEN WE
DON’T GO TO THE POLLS.
I ENCOURAGE PEOPLE EVEN THOUGH
THE BIDEN TEAM IS PLEASED THAT
THE POLLS ARE SHOWING HIM I HAD
TO COME UP WE CAN TAKE IT FOR
GRANTED AND THE FOCUS NEEDS TO
BE ON MAKING SURE THAT EVERY
SINGLE DEMOCRAT GETS OUT OF
VOTE.
BECAUSE IF THAT HAPPENS, BIDEN
WILL WIN.
>> Bret: THERE’S SOME
FRUSTRATION UP ON CAPITOL HILL
AND REPUBLICANS THOUGHT THEY
WERE CLOSE TO AT LEAST STARTING
THE CONVERSATION ON POLICE
REFORM.
TAKE A LISTEN SENATOR TIM SCOTT
ON THIS.
>> YOUNG AMERICANS OF ALL COLORS
ARE LOSING FAITH IN THE
INSTITUTIONS OF AUTHORITY AND
POWER.
IN THIS NATION.
BECAUSE WE ARE PLAYING SMALL
BALL, WE ARE PLAYING FOR THOSE
IN THE INSULATED FEVERS.
WE ARE PLAYING FOR PRESIDENTIAL
POLITICS.
>> Bret: DEMOCRATS LOST OF BLOCK
THE EFFORT TO GET THE BILL VOTED
OR AMENDED AND THERE IS
FRUSTRATION THAT THIS IS ALL
ABOUT POLITICS AND TRYING TO BE
A PRESIDENTIAL ISSUE.
HOW DO YOU RESPOND TO THAT?
>> I THINK IT’S DEFINITELY
FRUSTRATING FOR MANY OF US TO
SEE WHAT’S GOING ON IN CONGRESS.
OUR HOPE, MY HOPE IS THAT THE
MEANINGFUL POLICE REFORM WILL
COME OUT OF CONGRESS, BUT WHAT I
KNOW FROM BEING A MIRROR IS A
LOT OF THE LEADERSHIP HAPPENS ON
THE GROUND LEVEL FROM MIRRORS.
AND I KNOW POLICE REFORM IS
SOMETHING THAT MAYORS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY ARE TAKING A LOOK AT AND
THEY ARE ENGAGING WITH THEIR
CONSTITUENTS TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE POLICING FOR THE COMMUNITY
FITS WHAT THE COMMUNITY NEEDS.
SO WHILE I KNOW THAT IT’S
FRUSTRATING AND THAT THE REFORM
IS IN COMING OUT ON
CAPITOL HILL, THAT DOESN’T MEAN
THAT THE CHANGES ARE COMING.
>> Bret: SO YOU TELL YOUR
DEMOCRATIC COLLEAGUES ON THE THE
HILL MAYBE THEY SHOULD HAVE GONE
FORWARD AND TRY TO AMEND THE
BILL AND GET 70% OF IT, NOT
PERCENT?
>> YOU KNOW, I WOULDN’T -- NO, I
THINK IT’S IMPORTANT FOR THEM TO
STAND THEIR GROUND IN A WAY THAT
THEY THINK IS IMPORTANT.
THEY ARE THERE EVERY DAY, THEY
KNOW WHAT THEY NEED TO DO AND
GET DONE.
FOR ME, WHILE IT’S FRUSTRATING
THAT THERE ISN’T MORE COMING OUT
OF IT, WHAT I KNOW IS THAT AS
MUCH AS THEY ARE DOING, THE REAL
CHANGE HAPPENS ON THE GROUND.
THE WORK THAT THEY’RE DOING AND
CONGRESS ISN’T GOING TO CHANGE
THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
BILL OF RIGHTS IN MARYLAND WHICH
HAS TO BE AMENDED TO MAKE SURE
THAT MY POLICE COMMISSIONER
COULD ENFORCE AND TAKE
PRECAUTIONS WHEN IT’S NECESSARY
FOR OFFICERS WHO HAD COMMITTED
WRONGDOING.
>> Bret: I WENT TO PLAY ONE
MORE SOUND BITE FOR YOU AND THIS
IS BOB JOHNSON, TALKING TO FOX
EARLIER THIS WEEK.
>> VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN SAID TO
AFRICAN-AMERICANS, BLACK
AMERICANS ON HIS SHOW EVEN IF
YOU THINK ABOUT VOTING FOR
DONALD TRUMP, YOU’RE NOT RIGHT.
TO HAVE THAT MIND-SET, YOU MUST
HAVE THE ATTITUDE THAT WE BLACK
AMERICANS, WE OWN YOU.
WE CAN TAKE YOU FOR GRANTED.
THAT TO ME SHOWS YOU THAT BLACK
AMERICANS ARE AN APPENDAGE OF A
PARTY.
>> Bret: MAY BE BLACK LIVES
MATTER SHOULD START ITS OWN
PARTY, WHAT YOUR RESPONSE?
>> I THINK IT’S UNFORTUNATE THAT
HE TOOK WHAT BIDEN SAID FRONTED
BY A RADIO HOST OUT OF CONTEXT
AND DID SO IN A UNFORTUNATELY TO
BE MORE DIVISIVE.
I DON’T THINK IT’S A TIME FOR
THE COMMUNITY TO THINK ABOUT
BEATING THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY HAS
ALWAYS BEEN A PLACE WHERE
AFRICAN-AMERICANS AND IN MY
LIFETIME HAVE FOUND
OPPORTUNITIES FOR LEADERSHIP.
THE SECRETARY FOR THE DNC, YOU
KNOW, THERE’S SO MANY THAT HAVE
GONE BEFORE ME.
SO TO SAY THAT BECAUSE SOMETHING
THAT WAS INARTFULLY SET ON THE
TALK SHOW THAT AFRICAN-AMERICANS
ARE AN APPENDAGE OF THE PARTY, I
DON’T BELIEVE THAT TO BE THE
CASE AT ALL.
>> Bret: JUST WHAT I THINK
QUICKLY, NOTHING DIVISIVE, BUT
THERE ARE PARTS OF THIS MOVEMENT
THAT ARE TEARING DOWN MONUMENTS
AND STATUES BEYOND CONFEDERACIES
THAT SOME WOULD SAY ARE
DIVISIVE.
OUTSIDE THE NORM OF OUR PROCESS
OF GOVERNMENT.
WILL THE VICE PRESIDENT, FORMER
VICE PRESIDENT, SPEAK OUT ABOUT
THAT?
>> I THINK WHAT WE NEED TO HEAR
IS OUR PRESIDENT SPEAK OUT TO.
>> Bret: HE HAS BURIED >>
RACISM, AGAINST POLICE BRUTALITY
HE SPENT MORE TIME
DEFENDING THESE MONUMENTS OF THE
SOUTH, MONUMENTS OF THE
CONFEDERATES THAT WERE
ANTI-AMERICA, ANTI-U.S. AND
SPENT MORE TIME DEFENDING THEM
THAT HE HAS PROTECTING OVER
100,000 AMERICANS THAT HAVE DIED
FROM COVID.
HE’S GOT HIS PRIORITIES VERY
MIXED UP AND NEVER THINK IF YOU
FOCUSED ON LISTENING TO THE
PROTESTERS INSTEAD OF TRYING
TO INCITE VIOLENCE AND TO TRY TO
BOOST HIS POLL NUMBERS, I THINK
WE’D ALL BE BETTER OFF.
>> Bret: THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
HAS A DIFFERENT VIEW OF WHERE HE
IS AND WHAT HE SAID AND MAYOR,
WE APPRECIATE YOUR TIME AND